- All hour we are celebrating women
knocking down gender barriers in sports.
My next guest is certainly kicking
aside any hurdles in her way.
She's a two time all star
on the LA Sparks and she's
an NBA analyst for ESPN.
Please, everybody welcome Chiney Ogwumike.
(upbeat music plays)
(applause)
- You look so cute.
I wish we could hug.
And I wish I were tall.
(Chiney laughs)
- Oh, I'm five three it's so bad.
- I could throw you an inch or two.
- I was like, I'll take more than that.
So you basically have two full-time jobs.
I know how that feels.
And yeah, so how do you deal with it?
How do you balance?
- I don't, I really don't.
(Kelly laughs)
- I am horrible
- The honest answer folks.
- I'm really horrible at balance,
but I have a great team,
family, friends, agent
that really keeps me on point.
But I try my best to try to like
make sure everyone's proud with what,
you know, what I'm doing on
the court, off the court.
But it's hard to keep it all together,
but you take it one day at a time.
- I love that you're being
honest with it though.
Cause I love what I do too.
And I love, I love all
the jobs that I get to do,
but it is a very honest thing.
Like some days you have days
where you're just like,
(mimics explosion sound)
- Hibernate
- And tears.
- Yes
- That's normal for anyone even with
you know, one job, but
you have some pretty
successful women who've
mentored you, right?
- Correct.
- All right, Who or anybody you want to
talk about in particular?
Outside of my family,
I might have to go with probably,
you know, on the court Lisa Leslie.
I mean, she was the first one that said
I want to be just like her.
She's fierce.
She's feminine.
The first woman in the WNBA to dunk,
broadcaster, entrepreneur
she got 50, 11 jobs.
And so Lisa like even in my highs and lows
with injuries and setbacks,
she was always there for me.
And then I guess in the classroom,
cause I'm low key a nerd,
- I am a nerd, so you're welcome.
Welcome to Nerdville.
- Here we go, I love it.
Nerd nation, stand up.
So I went to Stanford
university and when I was,
- I am not that cool of a nerd,
you just, wow, that just happened.
Okay, It's been a good time.
Like, whoa, that's really cool.
I wish I could be a Stanford nerd.
I'm like your basic run of the mill nerd.
- No you're honorary Stanford.
- Okay, cool.
Yeah, no, I totally am with you now.
So on my official visit to Stanford
when I was in high school,
I had the nerdiest, the
nerdiest sort of official visit.
You know, this is where
they try to recruit you
to go to the school.
And so, you know, usually you
get those celebrities there.
Like we had John Elway
which is a sports celebrity.
Secretary Condoleezza Rice was there.
- Wow.
And then also Chief Justice John Roberts
was there at that pregame.
So I was like nerd and I was like,
Oh my gosh this is the
place that I want to be.
You know, going hard both,
you know, on the court.
But then also off the court,
you know, aspirations academically.
And so I go to Stanford
and we have this huge win.
We beat UConn like one of their
80 or so game win streaks.
And after the game we have
a lot of our, you know,
famous notable professors, alumni there.
They come to our locker room.
And you know, Secretary
Condoleezza Rice comes in.
I'm like, Oh, she don't remember me.
You know, I was just a little kid.
I was baby.
And so as we were leaving the locker room,
she was like, "Hey Chiney."
I was like, Oh she remember me?"
I was like, what?
She's like "Chiney I heard,
I remember when we met
a couple of years ago,
you're interested in politics,
government affairs,
international relations.
So why don't we meet?"
And I was like, Oh snap.
So like next day I was like, okay,
I'm going to follow up.
So I went to her office and she-
- Were you nervous?
- Was I nervous?
- God!
- Okay, So this is the funny part.
So I go there and she says,
"Chiney like have you been
raising your hand in class?"
"Have you been participating?"
I was like, nah, like I'm nervous.
This is Stanford like, I knew
in high school I was smart,
but like Stanford smart,
is a different level of intimidation.
So I go and she's like,
"Chiney you just like,
played UConn on national television."
"And you could like play
basketball in front of millions
of people, but you can't
raise your hand in class?"
- Well, that's different.
- It is different.
But I was like, I get your point.
- Okay. That's different.
That's like I don't like speaking
in front of people like a speech,
but I can sing in front
of billions and be fine.
- See it's a game mode.
- Yeah.
- It's a game mode.
- Yeah, you psych yourself, yeah.
- Exactly.
And so when she made that point
she started challenging me
to be as good as I can be
on the court, but also
understand that my energy
can also go off the court as well.
And that's academics.
And so as a freshman, it
sort of reset my mind.
And so she's been a huge mentor for me.
She actually was running
the international relations
department at Stanford.
So I chose that major.
And then she gave me my
diploma on graduation.
And so she's my major advisor.
- Man.
- What a beautiful life, you're only 29.
Look at all the cool things you've done.
And I think I want to point this out.
Like the thing I love about sports ball,
that's what I call it, is it
creates so much opportunity.
I have friends that
wouldn't have been able to
get into college, couldn't afford it,
but because of scholarships,
because of sports they were able to.
So I think that, and then
like you said off, you know
academically speaking that helps getting
into such a great school and
then having that diploma.
That's, there's just so
much opportunity there.
- Parents are happy
- It's so cool.
Yeah, I bet, yeah.
They're not sad.
I can promise you that.